Essence with the Western legal tradition
and societal norms and that the
political and supremacist character
given to it by contemporary Islamic
jihadists is an extraneous and
non-essential element of Islam that can
safely and fully be excised from Muslim
communities in Europe and the US which
will then take their place alongside
other Faith communities within the
existing social
contract so where and when exactly does
islamism or more precisely political
Islam originate many ascribe it to
Hassan Alana the founder of the Muslim
Brotherhood in his establishment of the
Brotherhood itself in
1928 and his formulation of Islamic
Theology and law that was later
crystallized by s kutub in his writings
in the 1950s and 60s albana and kutub
along with their Pakistani counterparts
S Abu Allah maudi presented their view
of Islam as a recovery of the
traditional and true Islam in its
fullness
as essentially a political movement as a
political movement at it in its at its
very core they saw the Brotherhood as an
effort to restore elements of Islam that
for a variety of reasons had fallen by
the wayside and particularly the
political character of Islam itself that
had decayed During the period of the
deine of the Ottoman Empire and was
destroyed altogether when Kamal Ataturk
abolished the caliphate in
1924 now those events and the founding
of the Muslim Brotherhood certainly are
watershed moments in the history of
political Islam but do they actually can
they actually be said to be the origin
of political Islam itself and thus can
be separated out from Islam itself
leaving a religion that is perfectly
compatible with the role that religions
have his historically played in the west
and play
today now this is I hope everyone
understands a very crucial question to
ask it is very important to understand
the relative relationship between
islamism and Islam and Islam or
political Islam and religious Islam
because involved in this answer are all
manner of policy decisions that flow
from the differing assumptions that one
may have and a great deal right now is
riding in the West in Europe and to a
lesser extent in the United States on
the idea that islamism is an extraneous
element of Islam that can safely be
excised and that Muslim communities in
the west will after this is done pose no
difficulty a great deal of policy has
been built on that
assumption and so the one thing that has
not been done is to ex examine that
assumption itself and to assess whether
or not it's true it would seem to me
that should have been done in the first
place before the policies were made but
since we're now in an age when first
we'll pass the bill and then we'll read
it it perhaps is in line with the
prevailing political
culture now no one of course wants to
face this question no one really wants
to ask this question because it appears
to involve Us in some very ugly
implications uh if islamism is an
essential or inherent element of Islam
if that is political Islam is part and
parcel of the thing
itself if political if Islam is
inherently political and supremacist
well then many fear that there's nothing
that can be done about the growing
Muslim communities in the west and that
this will inevitably lead to uh Terrible
Things Mass deportations
genocide these things have prevented
these fears have prevented people from
looking at this question realistically
and squarely but it is never sound
policy to base one's actions on the fear
of what may happen if something is true
if the truth is true then it is what it
is and we have to deal with it and there
are any number of positive steps that
can be taken in line with
judeo-christian values and with the
legal tradition of the West that have
nothing to do with mass deportation or
genocide or any other terrible moral
evil and yet none of the steps that can
be taken that would be realistic and in
line with our Traditions can be taken
unless we face this problem
realistically to start
with I remember once I was in a debate
about the uh nature of Islam and the
teachings of the Quran and Muhammad
about Warfare and my opponent in the
debate after I had uh made a state he
said if what Mr Spencer is saying is
true it's very
discouraging and based the the his
response on the fact not that it was
false but just that it was difficult it
was
depressing and it's certainly true that
in America especially we always want
Solutions and people generally tend to
think that you failed in an analysis if
you cannot provide a way to solve the
problem some problems are insoluble I'm
sorry to tell you however everything can
be ma every problem can be managed and
this is a problem that can be managed
but only if it's properly
understood now when's
islamism islamism political Islam was
founded not in 1928 but in
622 uh 622 is the year of the Hijra when
Muhammad moved from Mecca to Medina and
became for the first time a political
and a military
leader and as if emblematic of how
essential this is considered considered
by Muslims by Islamic tradition in
general to be to Islam
itself the Islamic calendar does not
begin with what one might expect as a
Westerner it does not begin with the
birth of Muhammad or the death of
Muhammad or the first revelation from
Allah to Muhammad the year one of the
Islamic calendar is the first year of
the Hijra of when Islam became for the
first time a political and a social
system and not simp simply an individual
religious faith and a matter of one's
individual
piety and thus was emphasized the
essential character of the political
aspects of
Islam Muhammad according to the Quran as
was mentioned earlier actually is an
excellent example of conduct Al alhas
and when he
became for the first time a political
and military leader and established
Islam as a political system this is
behavior that is considered exemplary
for all time and indeed became codified
in Islamic law precisely as such now
when one turns to the Quran one finds
traces of the these kinds of teachings
in it most infamously is Sur Surah N9 of
the Quran which in its entirety is a
Manifesto for aggressive Warfare against
non-believers most particularly in verse
29 of chapter 9 of the Quran which is a
mandate to wage war particularly against
Jews and Christians and the verse says
those who do not believe in Allah and
the last day even among the people of
the book which is the quranic term for
Jews and Christians
primarily and do not hold as unlawful
that which Allah and his messenger have
declared to be unlawful and do not
follow the True Religion fight against
them until they pay the gizia which is a
tax with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued so they have to pay
this tax they have to feel themselves
subdued in other words the Muslims are
commanded to fight against non-muslims
particularly Jews and Christians until
they are subjugated and accept a
secondary position in the society now
this is one verse out of a big book and
of course many people will say well the
Bible has violent passages in it as well
and so we have to look at the entire
interpretive tradition that is connected
with the book and with the entirety of
the book itself that's completely
reasonable but when we do the news
doesn't get any better because there are
tolerant and peaceful verses in the
Quran that is certainly true IB isak
Muhammad's earliest biographer taught
that the passages that mandated violence
against unbelievers like the one I just
read to you take precedence because they
follow chronologically later in
Muhammad's career they take precedence
over the more peaceful and tolerant
verses that came earlier and that too
became mainstream Islamic Theology and
was repeated Ed by numerous Islamic
scholars and theologians down through
the centuries to the present day all the
schools of Islamic jurist Prudence
without exception every last one of them
teaches that it is the
responsibility of the umah the Islamic
community worldwide to wage war against
unbelievers in order to establish them
as subservient under Islamic law until
they pay the jiz with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued now this is
not saying that all Muslims are
terrorists or all Muslims are evil or
some such in ways that this this
argument has been caricatured there are
obviously many Muslims not interested in
pursuing this program simply because
they have other things to do they have
other priorities in their lives they
have other things on their mind there is
in Islam as well as in every other
religious tradition among the Believers
a spectrum of belief of knowledge and
Def fervor the teachings of the religion
are one thing and the way in which any
individ ual puts it into practice are
another however if we take that fact as
evidence for the existence of a
theologically and juridically viable
form of
Islam that contains no political or
supremacist aspects we're just whistling
in the dark it does not
exist there is no such thing there are
in other words peaceful and moderate
Muslims
certainly there is no no peaceful or
moderate
Islam there is no formulation of Islam
that is mainstream or traditional or has
any standing within the Islamic world
that does not contain this Manifesto for
Warfare and conquest and
subjugation reformers do exist and in so
far as they are sincere in so far as
they are genuine and I say that make
that caveat because there are a great
many who uh
very slightly use language in ways that
most westerners are not aware of what
they're doing and they're actually
making a case for Sharia while appearing
to do something quite different but
genuine reformers do exist however
placing High Hopes upon them runs the
risk of exalting Fringe characters or
these deceivers who have little or no
influence in the Islamic World itself to
the status of spokesman for the Islamic
community and that's actually being done
to a tremendous degree most particularly
in the United States and in Great
Britain there are uh people who have
constructed Islamic groups who have
constructed a new Islam their own
private
Islam and have rejected terrorism
although often that term itself is not
defined or if it is defined it's defined
in a uh uh very misleading way and they
are G and they have no following with
within the Islamic community as a whole
but they actually have a quite large
following among non-muslims who wish to
be
reassured and who wish to feel better
about this whole problem and wish it
weren't quite as bad as it is and I
understand the impulse but really if
we're going to do anything serious to
save Europe at this point then it seems
to me to be absolutely essential in the
first place that we'd be realistic about
the nature of the problem
itself uh for example in regard to these
reformers there is a group The F Council
of North America f is Islam is Islamic
jurist prudence and the FI Council of
North America has issued on several
occasions actually with great Fanfare
and tremendous enthusiastic press
coverage a condemnation of
terrorism and it sounds great Muslims
condemn terrorism we have nothing to do
with any of this read the document and
there is a condemnation of attacks on
innocent civilians
read the Quran there is no indication
anywhere in all its many many many
denunciations of unbelievers that the
unbelievers are innocent there is no
such concept within traditional Islamic
teaching the unbelievers are not in good
faith they never act in good faith it is
actually a a a a very widespread element
of Islamic theology that non-muslims
know full well that Islam is true but
they refuse to accept it and they refuse
to become Muslims out of a desire for
financial gain or social status or some
other base motive there's even a story
in Islamic tradition of a delegation of
Christians who went to see Muhammad the
prophet of Islam and along the way on
the way the leader of this delegation of
Christians he turns to the rest of them
and he says we know this man is a
prophet we know that he fits all the
prophecies about the next prophet in our
holy
books however the byzantines pay us a
good living and if we if we acknowledge
him as a prophet they'll cut us off and
so we have to go in and oppose
him and this is not just one isolated
story this is how unbelievers are always
presented in Islamic tradition they know
better I can tell you personally I get
emails all the time from Muslims very
frequently and they say you know Islam
is true and you're just trying to make
some money as if there's money in this
and I understand where they're coming
from because this is what they are
taught but the point is is that there is
no innocent non-muslim in Islamic
Theology and so to condemn an attack on
innocent civilians does not condemn any
terrorist attack as we understand
them it leaves a wide enough loophole to
fit 9911
in and the July 7th bombings in London
and all the rest of them
so above all it is imperative at this
time that we avoid fantasy based
policymaking and fantasy-based
Analysis the implications of what I'm
saying are very bad I don't mean there's
no way to sugarcoat them but there are
precedents and there are useful ways
forward if we have the courage to face
this problem as it truly is this is a
problem within Islamic teaching within
core Islamic teaching founded on the
Quran as such wherever there are Islamic
communities there will be terrorism and
efforts to impose elements of Islamic
law through peaceful means to assert the
Precedence of Islamic law over the laws
of the state in which the Muslims happen
to be residing that will always happen
now
1945 the MacArthur government that
occupied the occupational government in
Japan issued an edict saying that Shinto
the religion of the Japanese that had
fueled Japanese Imperial militarism in
World War II would have no interference
from the United States occupying forces
as a an expression of individual piety
as the religion of of any Japanese
citizen no interference whatsoever from
the government however Shinto would have
no role in the government or in the
schools and the distinction was made it
was imposed from
without
that Shinto would have no way to express
the political militarism that had led to
World War II in the first place now the
United States Great Britain
Europe are all facing a very similar
problem with growing Muslim communities
asserting political and societal Notions
that are at variance with our ideas of
the freedom of speech the freedom of
conscience the equality of Rights of
women with men the equality of Rights of
all people before the
law if our governments had the courage
to stand up and say that any assertion
of these political aspects of Islam that
are at variance with our existence
laws will be considered to be seditious
under existing sedition laws that would
be a tremendous amount of progress made
on this
problem but of course we're nowhere near
that because we can't even admit that
there are such initiatives going on from
the Islamic communities as
such and so as long as this unrealism
persists then the difficulties the
cognitive dissonance will continue to
grow and as long as the cognitive
dissonance continues to th grow so also
will the assertiveness and belligerence
of the Islamic communities in the west
because they will see that we are not
able and not willing to take the
decisive steps necessary to do anything
serious to stop them thanks very
[Applause]
much thank you very much for that Robert
um to guide us through some more uh
onlyy issues now